it is March 16 2023 and you're watching
the code report but well hello my fellow
printers yesterday mid-journey released
its version 5 model in Alpha and the AI
images it can produce are shockingly
realistic like the guy with the shocked
face that got you to click on this video
is 100 artificial as a programmer and
content creator who recently lost his
job to AI I've been looking for a new
line of work my initial thought was to
get into modeling because my mom says
I'm extremely good looking unfortunately
I found out that models are now obsolete
it's now possible to generate them in
all shapes and sizes and you'll never
know the difference unless you look
really closely at the fingers there are
many different companies and projects
competing to be the best generative
image model in 2023 stable diffusion is
the leading open source project then you
have tons of closed Source projects like
Dolly from open Ai and countless others
trying to monetize the space but in my
opinion mid-journey is the most
impressive place to prove the images
just pop they're vibrant realistic and
aesthetically pleasing for that we
shouldn't be thanking mid-journey but
all the photographers and artists Who
unwillingly provided the data set to
create this black magic that will make
the their sons and daughters obsolete
interestingly the U.S copyright office
just recently ruled that generative AI
art cannot be copyrighted because you
need to show proof of human authorship
if you take some AI art and modify it as
a human then it could become eligible
but it's reviewed on a case-by-case
basis that's good news because it means
grifters can't just prove something out
and license it to you as a copyrighted
work the ones who will make the most
Bank in this movement are the ones who
provide the models like mid-journey and
open AI open AI started as a non-profit
but then transitioned to for-profit when
they realized how much mother F and
money they were going to make on this
thing in any case I'm happy to pay 10
bucks a month for co-pilot 20 bucks a
month for chat GPT and 10 bucks a month
for mid-journing together they put
almost all of human creativity at your
fingertips making you a demigod in the
digital world at the same time it will
likely ruin creativity because who wants
to create art when you know some
company's just going to steal it and
remix it into an infinite number of
variations to the point where nobody can
tell the difference it takes the
incentive away from True human Talent
Feast your eyes on this toad had you
told me Alex Gray painted it I'd believe
you but he didn't I'm guessing his
artwork is in the mid-journey data set
but this is my artwork I proved it at
fair and square and here's how you can
do it too mid journey is handled
entirely in Discord there's currently no
API but I imagine that's coming someday
once in the Discord all you have to do
is go into one of the Newbie channels or
your direct messages and type in the
Imagine slash command from there just
describe whatever image you have in your
imagination and let it go to work
congratulations you can now put prompt
engineer on your resume it'll create
four different variations of your idea
then you can choose one of them to make
even more variations or you can choose
to up sample them individually currently
version 5 is an alpha and if you want to
use it use the V flag at the end of your
prompt to get highly realistic images of
humans I would also recommend adding the
Q flag as 2 to increase the quality
there's all kinds of different
parameters you can use to change the
output some of the most useful ones
include aspect ratio do change the shape
of the image and chaos to control the
amount of craziness the higher the chaos
the more random stuff you might get in
the output image what's especially
awesome though is that you can also
provide a starter image which can just
be a hyperlink to any image URL on the
internet that means if you have a long
lost relative you can bring them back to
life in new artwork and photos it's not
going to be deep fake accurate but it's
still pretty creepy all of this
generative AI stuff might seem
terrifying if you're a digital Creator
however there is one glimmer of hope
it's very possible that you were made
with AI and if you can't tell the
difference then what does it matter this
has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]